so guys bill welcome back holiday
edition
Christmas week edition where we talk
about the Jenna Julian things amongst
the other things in this week amongst
the harder things I guess right because
it's all in it
we've got the dogs in hopefully they're
gonna be good it's gonna be a family
podcast family podcast I see the family
and relax okay
yes um it was late so patiently while
we're podcasting so this is really
exciting though are you guys excited
you're not normally allowed yeah you're
in the room you're not allowed to be in
and you're on the table
um and I'm still Julian I have shorter
hair for those of you haven't seen but I
study house with your haircut first
podcaster hey it's great you look great
no no nodding your nose on the mic you
giant baby girl stay so we decided this
week with your help on Twitter some of
you who are curious this podcast has his
own Twitter account Gemma Julian pod on
Twitter and we reached out and we did a
little pull and you guys chose the Q&A
for this week and I honestly can't think
of a time on the podcast at all that we
did just a straight-up Q&A so did my mom
no but like just uh oh yeah like asking
us questions we've no I don't think
we've done it you got to stay you got to
stay young Pete's bad family aim so what
we did is uh gathered a bunch of your
questions and we are just going to
answer them on the podcast right now
just two guys to give you guys that
because I know you guys like that
normally we have discussions guests
whatever else but I figured it was kind
of fitting for this week it's like a
nice family week everyone's probably
with their families hopefully you're in
a place you're happy with right now with
the holidays and family and everything
what's up yeah hopefully you're
surrounded by people that love and
support you and if you're not there's
always the Internet there you go
we care there we go that's exactly right
yeah uh so we are both gonna answer your
questions now
thank you for sending questions by the
way and now we're going to our answer I
want to go to the beginning
banana banana down with the sadness
that's a great song to clean too by the
way just what we did earlier yeah we
just turned on down with the sickness I
disturbed if I could clean the whole
house it damaged your energy Schatzi
SATA become wants you to pattern okay
just pattern hold your hand like this
and just pet it face okay well first
question well what are you guys doing or
what do you normally do for Christmas
well this year let me see the name sorry
Mary Kate Cassidy asked that ah well
since I've lived on the west coast I
don't I haven't gotten home for
Christmas like ever because as soon as I
moved to California my mom was like
great I'll come visit you because it's
warm and there's no snow and when you
live in a place like Rochester I imagine
you'll take every opportunity you can
get to get out of the snow so I haven't
been going home in a lot of years my mom
will come visit and my brother lives in
Oregon so for the past two years now
since they had my niece I we've been
driving up to Oregon to see them and the
years before that they would drive down
to LA and stay with me but now that they
have the babies the babies um yeah you
just go up there so it'll make it easier
for everybody so which is really nice
we've done we've done it once before
together and we're gonna do it again
this year it's very nice good Drive and
um yeah we don't spend a lot of time
there and now it's like a road trip yeah
coldest time any time that we get to
travel with the dogs is like a vacation
to me absolutely you know there Tom what
did you used to do for Christmas did
were you more like Hanukkah or Christmas
sauces but my dad was Kristin's mom's
Hanukkah but you know when I when I went
to college
and it started to be less and less of a
thing you know um I would mostly just go
to my mom's and like do the you know
holiday thing that your Christmas
Hanukkah thing and hang out with all
five of my siblings and step-siblings so
many siblings it was always just like
that um in the last couple of years
though um I think what we went to my to
Big Bear to celebrate that was
Thanksgiving though together a while ago
that was like two years ago yeah
I really had like a family Thanksgiving
we've last year we went and visited your
family we're doing that again this year
my mom kid here no we went business
we went visited your brother last year
yeah for Christmas that's actually
Thanksgiving
no no I'm talking about Christmas I
haven't had like a family Christmas or
Hanukkah in a couple years which I don't
think is a thing because it's not really
a giant event anymore but um hopefully
that answered your question
yeah like if you get older and you
travel like we do no presents I talked
about that like if you have to travel to
each other
no presents and we also decided a long
time ago that like for Christmas and and
Thanksgiving that sometimes it's easier
just to pick one you know like if your
family only gives you therefore one I'd
say we usually pick Christmas over
Thanksgiving yeah so then move [ __ ] here
yeah for sure Natalie we're sorry Wow
Nicole Valley her valet or VA has a
favorite alcohol for Christmas for
Christmas
oh I know yours what's my Bailey's Oh
Bailey's I love Bailey's and loves it
right you know what peach can she come
come here oh you're in trouble yes your
blood baby girl on daddy's laughing
she's too wily to Wiley's meld with the
baby energy Kermit you have the whole
bed to yourself oh good boy um yeah I
love Bailey's Bailey's is one of those
drinks that I won't like go out and get
drunk off but when I'm like feeling
festive and I want something sweet
just Bailey's on the rocks is like so
nice that thank you for reminding me
because I want to have a Bailey's now
yeah usually get on planes I do I drink
it on planes I don't that like be big a
major tradition when Wow good worse when
we went to Ireland yeah and we were
flying Island so I was like hey we're
flying island might as well get in the
spirit have a Bailey's and then from
every flight I've ever drank on after
that I've gotten a Bailey's yeah what
feel like it's like long international
flights where they bring you a drink
with your dinner or whatever yeah
on your like please [ __ ] environment
yeah like how they're like what do you
want for lifts off and then pre liftoff
and then during liftoff and then
afterwards yeah I just want Bailey's you
know I'm so dehydrated right now yeah
what is yours the other holiday drink
feeling you don't really like that melt
those milky things no and I love eggnog
though she that's her favorite drink it
makes me want to throw up I really don't
like it my mom likes that she used to
drink it when we were kids and just the
smell of it makes me like completely
nauseous it's disgusting
do you have a festive drink that you can
think of I like hot choke hot chocolate
hot cocoa hot cocoa is good yeah but
there's not a whole lot of good I
haven't had one since Meighan please no
vegan so I don't know if it exists yeah
but I probably just have like a coffee
hmm sorry for not being that fat suit
like a peppermint what a peppermint
stick in there and then everything is
great mmm well how [ __ ] dare you
but Rose / one ot says what kind of
presence do you get each other okay
here's the thing though is that I'm
always a big like pusher of no presence
because I think it's I don't know it you
can get people that you care about
presence and Julian always breaks it he
always gets me a present but like I
don't know I'm sort of like let's not
get each other anything maybe we can
come together and buy each other a
present like we were talking in one of
my vlogs about how maybe we'd get a new
couch soon we should do that even if
it's after Christmas we should have a
holiday like couch for us we need a we
need to get that because we really could
use a new couch yeah but I don't know if
I get Julian something it's just I don't
know something more thoughtful than like
oh here's a fancy present for you yeah
yeah it's I mean I've all I've always
wanted to get you at least a little
something just to show you that you know
I'm thinking about you and then the time
of like giving and stuff but it's never
a big production with us we don't we
don't like all right it's gif night what
do you got hubby you know like stuff
like that it's very like low-key if we
do it at all sometimes we'll just agree
on no gifts I'll get her something small
anyway and then we just move on it's
fine like this we're not you know I
don't I don't treat the holidays as just
gift season sit yeah well we get each
other a lot of stuff during the
your size uh yeah we do we do gonna have
to kick her out now she's like she's
like swiping with her giant man hands
she's like oh yeah never go well she was
her own gender bebe bebe sue on Twitter
wrote what's your favorite Christmas
movie mine is Scrooged oh I have to say
that one of my all-time best Christmas
story and then Christmas movie I was
probably thinking of a Christmas sir I
love a Christmas story [ __ ] movies
supporting car and elf
I really like else I actually have elfin
one of mine the other one is jingle all
the way with Arnold Schwarzenegger love
that movie really one of my favorites
you serious yeah it's great movie I
guess I haven't seen it a lot of years I
don't remember if it's good it's really
funny I mean I haven't seen it since I
was kid so much suck but I loved it I
was a kid you love the way it makes you
feel yeah not petting her so she stays
um I like a Christmas story because we
would just sort of let that play on TV
well right after your dumpling all be on
it's like your presents and you eat your
breakfast with your family then we would
sort of just let it play and then hang
out and have family ten yeah so that
that movie is very Christmas yeah but
I'm not like a huge fan of all the weird
like claymation like that weird chin I
remember something like it's weird yeah
really [ __ ] weird yeah yeah other
than that my best friend's wedding
probably I'm not bi you know I feel
about the movie it's great it's a great
one Ian Hathaway sucked in that movie
good podcast joke thank you um yeah one
good answer
Suzy asks what's your favorite moment
you've spent together so far Oh peach
eat you're being neighbors no I'm no but
he just like it's bothering me because
she's just like I embracing all the
attachment on no she's going on my shirt
that's going into jail what's your
favorite moment Julian it's hard to say
um
I don't know there's been a little
naughty dog way to being naughty we
spent a lot of really great moments
together um I don't know I just I love
like a lot of the time we spend together
we're not doing anything spectacular or
cool even though a lot of time we are
like we get to go you know obviously one
thing that sticks out is you know seeing
more than once but amongst all the times
you've been really honored to you know
do certain things or have opportunities
like your wax figure sticks out because
that was a really really proud moment
for me um I don't know I escaped to Big
Bear we escaped and do these little
drives we you know when we first met we
would go on these nighttime drives just
to drive around just me and her in the
car right and I really loved those like
those those stick with me there's not a
single moment that all the moments have
really just kind of made it great I feel
exactly I'm waiting I can't like
pinpoint something that was more special
or fun or nice or anything more than the
others it's just a collective body of
like a really nice feeling yeah for
several years so I think that's yeah
also the time I proposed to you that was
a really great moment my wife he if
you're confused I put up a vlog like
earlier today that was uh we're sitting
in bed and I credited Julianne with
having the incredible joke of any time
he's doing something annoying he's like
yeah well you married me because we're
not [ __ ] married and it's really
funny he'll do something you're like I
mean I'm your husband
so yeah you got to deal with it yep that
it's Frank Joe I got this I thought it
was decent
I would I feel like if I had to pick
anything I'd say the time that we were
in Big Bear with your family do you
remember that yes I do that was one of
the best times ever for Thanksgiving and
we were all just hanging out and like
drinking and having fun and the time
that our moms came over for Mother's it
was a great moment it was a great day
I loved that I was mother
and our moms were just like so happy
there's something about like seeing your
mom really happy that just like makes
everything really nice so when my mom is
having fun with your mom and our moms
are happy and we're just both looking at
each other like we did it me do for
crushing Mother's Day right now like how
you're talking about like remember like
we fed them mimosas and put them in the
pool like they were so happy it was such
a great day it was a great day uh Ali
says for Jenna
do you miss white Christmases you know
that's a good question it's a good
question because I know honestly the
concert I mean I do um but it's it's a
little bit bigger than just Christmas I
don't care if it's Christmas and there's
no snow
all right I'm really like it's not I
don't care but I do miss weather I don't
miss the extreme amount of weather that
I grew up with like in in Rochester it's
not a joke you know winter lasts the
better part of the [ __ ] year and it
is exhausting it's really hard to you
know stay happy and up all the time I
think there's a significant increase in
your level of positivity and happiness
when you're in a place where just simple
things like the weather just aren't
getting in your way and like I feel like
I was getting pretty hard in Boston
because the whole weather it's just it's
a different situation there's nowhere to
put the snow so everyone is like [ __ ]
each other over for parking spots and
like you have to shovel out your spot
for two hours and then someone will take
it and that's enough to drive any sane
person completely crazy for a small
period of time no but I would say that I
I miss weather in seasons more than I
miss having like a white Christmas I
don't really care if it [ __ ] there's
snow around for Christmas that's what I
would I would I'm kind of like a little
bit of a [ __ ] outdoorsy person
anyways as it is like we grew up camping
and we go to my cottage like you know
[ __ ] just now we love hikes I don't I
haven't done a lot of that as an adult
which is what I would say that I miss
because when I'm around that stuff I'm
like right back into the love doing all
that [ __ ] and I'm have
although you get to spend more time of
the year outside here I feel like
there's just a little bit less to take
in sort of you get to look at the ocean
it's beautiful there's beautiful hikes
and mountains but like you can't go
[ __ ] do all the weird [ __ ] that you
do in the woods and the lake and [ __ ]
yeah you know yeah I don't know I don't
know what I'm saying
but I do miss the East Coast or at least
an area that was not like an arid dry
vapid wasteland that is calc California
fair enough but that's why we like Big
Bear because there's trees and mountains
that's where it's a quick yeah yeah you
get a quick amount of weather and nice
like you're you're not exactly living
you got to rough it a little bit really
[ __ ] nice although that place that
we've been staying at we're not roughing
it there no but yeah Alan have you ever
had a white Chris yeah I thought you
were gonna ask it was in New Jersey
Hoboken New Jersey that's right yeah my
stepmom was just my dad's girlfriend at
the time but my stepmom I had invited us
so we went out there for Christmas I was
with my dad for Christmas anyway so we
were just like you know what's you know
we'll go home Christmas with dad and his
girlfriend and it was really nice I have
really great memories from that time
like you know we had the fire going you
know we were sleeping downstairs in the
basement like it was like we had our
beds together it was very festive we
played board games watch a Christmas
story went out and threw snowballs like
it was very you know it's very fun and I
think it was extra special because I
never had had a white Christmas I've
been to the snow before but not for
Christmas so it was nice yeah it's nice
I mean we get that in the way playing
Stratego that's a great game that's what
yeah I was in love with that game we we
would get that in the winter though you
have those like weekend days with your
family or whatever where you're just in
the house it's warm you're cozy but
after [ __ ] so many months of that
like come February and March you're like
all right dude good I need to go outside
or else I'm going to lose my kid yeah I
can't relate to that at all
I mean I imagine exactly what you're
saying is what it's like but um all
right well what's the worst gift you've
ever gotten from Blake uh I actually
remember the worst gift I've ever gotten
I was a kid my mom and her mom
a relatively complicated relationship
although her mother's passed away but
when we were kids she lived in like
Florida I think and she would mail us
like these big boxes of [ __ ] like actual
[ __ ] like she would go to a thrift store
and pick out like kooky old lady [ __ ]
not like literal poop though no no no
but it was always very sweet like she
would send us gifts my mom was very
appreciative yeah but she would send us
a giant box of like everything that's
been sitting in your local thrift store
for years because literally no one wants
it and I think my mom like should be
like all right Merry Christmas this is
from your grandma like why don't you
guys open this up first because it's
gonna get weird yeah and we had pulled
out this pair of ski goggles
we don't ski nobody [ __ ] skis it's
made for an adult we're both like tiny
little children we pull out this pair of
ski goggles it was like covered in human
hair and like dog hair mother and my mom
just took it and looked at it and was
like okay let's just why don't you guys
open your presents oh no mom we want to
see what's in it like what's in here cuz
when you're kid you don't care
it's [ __ ] exciting it's Christmas huh
but uh that was probably the worst my
mom was like and this is covered in hair
um would you guys like to open your
presents from me yeah so probably that
but it was never because I didn't want
it or because like someone got me
something that was bad it was literally
just like sometimes your family gonna go
and get a little they're crazy on you
boo-boo they're gonna send you some
human hair attached to ski goggles right
am I'm really trying to put them put
them on my face I mom be like no no no
no no give him to me give him to me but
no this is not a game it's not funny
give him I was a kid and our cousin's
visited us for the holidays and I grew
up in Southern California so you guys
are aware of what weather I have and my
aunt gave he brought stuff like gifts
for us in our step siblings so both
you want to include everyone so I
remember we were opening gifts from her
and they open like a couple LEGO sets
and I was young but they open a couple
Lego sex sets sex Lego sex mmm and I was
like damn that's sick if my step-brother
got Lego said I wonder what I'm gonna
[ __ ] yet over my present and it was
an umbrella hell yeah eyebrow I got an
umbrella for business but I never would
have ever used give a child an umbrella
yeah you go dude like as this design one
never rains here
it was pissed as I was my mom and I just
died laughing about it afterwards
because it was one that I just got an
umbrella it was that my step-brother got
a Lego set and I got a brother the
contrast that made me like it was so
funny oh there's the worst case I've
ever gotten for sure that's pretty sad
yep Stephanie our girl Stephanie Sierra
asks what is your favorite holiday
mm it's definitely not [ __ ] New
Year's I hate New Year's New Year's is
pretty shitty New Year's is terrible to
me because like everyone is hyped it up
to be this epic night of like fun
whatever them in reality it's more like
you're sort of just rushing around to
get to wherever you're trying to go for
an amount of time for you to have fun
before it turns out at night yeah
whereas I don't know sometimes I don't
get my weekend or party nights together
much earlier than midnight so yeah like
all right [ __ ] I'm late
all right there it goes looks like
someone can die and get killed by drunk
drivers it is the worst day ever
I know the Super Bowl Sunday is the
number one for like duis and all that
but yeah something something a third is
like years yeah don't always remember
that though because I don't think a lot
of people know that the Super Bowl is
number one yeah that is one of those
stats where you're like no way but it's
a snowball sunnies I believe it's the
highest day for duis yes or at least has
been statistically in the past yeah but
New Year's is right up there so that's
you're not favored what is your favorite
let's get to your Alliance um I really
like Halloween okay
it's really [ __ ] fun Halloween's good
I like dressing up and I always make my
costume which is like a that's my thing
like true it's true but um I'm a big fan
of 4th of July Independence Day cuz
every time I think of that I think of
eating really good food barbecuing and
eating all day and having like a nice
little just like appreciation and like
with food freedom for freedom you know
food for freedom food for freedom I mean
ever since we've been together you've
kind of showed me the way to do it like
our first fourth of July together we
made those ribs even though we burnt the
first rack and then we had to get a
second rack but we like rub them and we
got the baked beans and the Mac and the
eggs it was just it was like that like
was the first time I had ever really
done up fourth of July and I really look
at wheat rice throughout the day just
and like as much as yeah you're drinking
and cooking and [ __ ] eating all day
like you do in the back your mind
understand that the day is to celebrate
your independence which is what you're
doing that day you're being independent
you making your own choices and having
some great food and drinks so but I
would say for you know that's a fourth
of July is a sleeper holiday yeah it's a
sleeper yeah great yeah when I was a kid
we used to spend it like at my cottage
with my dad and my dad would light off
fireworks off the dock yeah and he had
like gotten it down to a science because
in the state of New York you were
allowed to light off fireworks over
water but you are not allowed to
purchase them in that state so we were
drive to Pennsylvania he would buy a ton
of fireworks
that's and it's a small teeny tiny lake
in upstate New York off of the Finger
Lakes it's not even one of the big ones
and uh like I think there was like one
person across the lake that would light
off some little ones and dad like he
built a [ __ ] like shoot to launch
them like it got so intense to the point
where like when he was done with his
little show like you'd hear people
clapping across the lake that's awesome
that's really that was a great show this
year whoo
so but we do the same thing you spend
the day outside yeah with your friends
and your love and just eat and hang out
for sure it's good question keya
um asks us both what our favorite Jenna
hair color is her
oh I like the purple a lot that was one
my favorites yeah yeah I mean aside from
when I lived in Boston my friend al used
to cut my hair and he had literally he
was the one that started the whole
[ __ ] let's just do whatever to your
hair until it falls off in your bald and
he had cut my bangs into actual stairs
and he had died the underneath part
bright pink there so it was bleach
blonde and then left one SuperDuper long
piece in the back like a tapered piece
in the back and he had died that blue
and purple and he goes that's your tail
like it was like six inches longer than
the stairs he had cut into my hair like
he was just next-level I'm like do
whatever you want and he really [ __ ]
dead so it would be the stairs hair
stairs and a tail fair enough like it
looked crazy when I put it in a ponytail
there's like this one long tail coming
out it was pretty up yeah that's good
what was your favorite I have a couple
favorites one is a purple hmm below the
purple cuz for a while it was it was
like the first time I'd ever seen you
with dark hair oh yeah um I I still am a
big fan of your original bleach blonde I
think that looks super cute yeah um
purple that one um and most recently
this one I really like the the dual
color is really cool to me it's pretty
cool so you like the darker ones better
no cuz I like the blonde too like the
red was dope as [ __ ] to like you know
like it's hard to pick they're all
really cool I actually really really
like the red because at its brightest it
was bright red you know it was like the
cherry you're in it's really really cool
but the purple was just it was I just
remember this first time I saw you talk
hair yeah you're really cute um it's so
crazy when people say that to me because
I just remember when I was younger I had
a hairdresser I was like you know late
high school like about to go into
college yeah and I had the same
hairdresser and I'm like dude can you
please like I save up my money
I prefer [ __ ] so long to come here
and get my hair done can you please just
bleach it [ __ ] blonde and she looked
at me and was like I'm not gonna do that
unlike why she goes it would never look
right on
like you could never look good with
bleach blonde hair and I remember being
really upset but like I was still in
that mindset of like alright yeah your
hairdresser probably always knows dude
so it took me really knew didn't she
like the middle of college and I was in
Boston like you know you do when you
move to a new city if you're a girl that
likes to get their hair done yeah you do
that weird awful thing where you just
search for a good hairdresser for so
long and I finally found one and I just
brought her some pictures and I was like
do this or else I'm gonna [ __ ] leave
and she goes oh yeah sure like this
looks like you know I wanted it very
dark underneath and bleached blonde in
the top which was like the style at the
moment yeah and she was like yeah of
course and I'm like oh my god is this
really gonna happen and she [ __ ]
bleach the [ __ ] out of it and it looked
dope and then I never went back because
then once you go to a hairdresser with
bleach blonde in your hair they're like
cool yeah I'll just touch up your roots
it's ridiculous that but that type of
that the hairdresser that refused is
like a great example of shitty pride and
stubbornness getting in the way of your
business like you think you do you think
you're a know-it-all so you're like oh
no wouldn't look good then you make your
image blonde and then everyone in the
[ __ ] universe who saw your viral
videos like oh she looks great
like she's blonde you were the one
person on earth that said [ __ ] you you
diddly big [ __ ] barn here I hope she
kicks herself right now because I just
hate when people are like so prideful
like you're you're a hairdresser so you
know everything and you refused service
because of it you're like I'm not gonna
do that Wow [ __ ] yourself
oh my gosh look another horse my first
yeah my first hairdresser in LA was one
of the people so then you know fast
forward a few years she was the one
telling me you can't dye your hair any
other color cuz I'm like why don't we
try it why don't I have some brown or
something like do whatever you want but
like I would like it to be different
every time I get my hair done I don't do
it that often
so she was the one putting like just the
streaks of color in my hair for sure
because she told me that now that I'm
like a person where people have like an
understanding what I look like you can't
just not be blonde anymore like you're a
blonde and I was like I remember
secretly sitting there like you know I
have this theory of I'm gonna let my
hairdresser do whatever they want but if
this [ __ ] does not take a risk on my
head
we'll find somebody that well like she
moved yeah this is horribly off-topic
I'm sorry for going on no I just want to
quickly interject I don't mean to be a
dick and say you're a hairdresser like
nobody should be on the high horse I
came off kind of like okay that's good
um she had moved but like that's when we
broke up I never had like the boy never
had that moment where you do me like I'm
done with you stop doing my hair because
that's a tough moment well it's like
breaking up yeah it's really different
no way to do without being like you suck
right like why are you breaking over the
hairdresser either you're too expensive
or you suck hmm yeah both are like hard
to take from you from their perspective
but I mean that I found Kate and Kate is
always willing to just do crazy ass
shits in my head which I really
appreciate I got guy to know you do we
got a guy it's not a great feeling that
is what is written oh your hairdresser I
know a lot of girls like to get like
their nails under eyebrows like once you
find your person oh that's great feeling
look I remember when I used to get mad
before I grew up my hair
I used to get my hair cut like
relatively short like way shorter than
this like short on the sides short on
the top but a little longer than the
sides and I came to you that one day and
I was like I think I found the
hairdresser for me and you were like why
I was like he didn't say a single
[ __ ] word the whole time
okay so that was funny but um chance I
guess it's kind of different when you're
not just getting like a [ __ ] military
cut like I used to or whatever yeah um
anyway yeah uh Sonya krampus on Twitter
Simon asks who would win a UFC style
fight Santa or the Grinch ooh I would
put my money on Santa because he's in a
totally different weight class okay but
you're sleeping on the Grinch's ground
him because he's got those long limbs
and his his body is furry so you can tie
you up with chokes
arm locks grappling that the Santa just
won't have anything to do I mean once
you put Santa on his back the Grinch is
all over he's passing his guard is
threatening with submissions you know it
if the Grinch takes a shot though he
might get knocked out too I that's what
I was gonna say I think Santa has
someone punch like Saint country Rui
Nelson and he's very very right now
and he can throw some bombs and then he
says ho ho and the other thing is he's
like he's got a bunch of [ __ ] tag
team or teammates that he can just
tagging his reindeers noses [ __ ] you I
didn't know reindeers dude yeah he'll
jump on their hind legs and [ __ ] what
mrs. Claus can't get in there no that
would be a man versus a woman fan I'm
not in favor of that how do you know
that the Grinch is male [ __ ] you God let
the Grinch pick his own gender its own
gender oh goodness
anyways I don't know God Rose / 102
oh you already asked the question but
you also asked will you be attempting to
keep the tree up all year we're not
gonna have a tree this year guys I know
we blew it because we were gonna do it
last week and then anything we got busy
with other [ __ ] and then they realize
not worth it well we're going we're
leaving for Christmas we're going to be
on all all Christmas all the week
leading up so it's not going to be worth
it so no the answer is no we will not
have a Christmas tree up all year for
those who don't know a couple years ago
but prior to moving here we had our
Christmas tree up almost all year and
right before we were about to hit the
year mark we moved a note and then we
took it down so all right uh Jade MV if
you switched bodies what could be the
first thing you'd each do in your new
body this is very important for science
I already know I would pee on things
I've always said that it's pretty fun I
like I would go outside and I would
write my name in pee hmm like this might
be way TMI but like it looks so much
more fun to go to the bathroom for you
than to me yeah like you just look like
you get to do so many fun things and I
can't okay I would play with my boobs
yeah that's fair I play with my boobs on
the boobs and then I would go to a bar
and see how many free drinks I can get
oh right yeah I don't even bring my log
just go and see how many free jigs I can
[ __ ] get
hey big boy yeahyou has really done uh
it's like a the episode of Parks and Rec
where they're trying to get April and
Andy are trying to get free stuff all
over the bar and she's like I can get
this free drink he's like how she's like
I'm a girl so he turns she turns and
she's like hey how you doing you want to
get a drink and she's like yeah what do
you want he's like I got double whiskey
and then she gets a whiskey and he
starts talking uh she I like to drink
alone
chug turns away that's funny um Zoe asks
any Christmas vegan recipes Jenna or I
guess if you have any sources to look
for them if you don't have any on hand
for Zoe because she needs ideas I really
like hot for food they have a good
YouTube channel um
the cauliflower wings we did on my blog
was hot for food yeah um but I know I
had a turkey like I think it was
tofurkey that roast that I got for
Thanksgiving it wasn't my favorite I'll
probably not have it what about
Christmas if all that business though
guarding the company's walled garden how
you spell that G ard e i NK they make
like so many good like frozen stuff yeah
it's not ideal you don't want to be
eating one no but I've seen it they make
really really quality looking delicious
and they have a like a Thanksgiving
turkey one with gravy and like we can
find oh good I've even tried to order
online yeah places we're sold out of
them for Thanksgiving because that's how
good they are
hmm but that place if you wanted like
not to cook a bunch then you could
totally do that
um but hot for food I've seen they do
really good like seasonal recipes well
so much i watch somebody else I don't
know
forget it mine bother her on Twitter
later if you want her to remember that
yes she will yeah there's lots of good
stuff out there um favorite Suzy asks
our favorite dj khaled quote really
quickly I was when I interject
dj khaled has quickly become the number
one funny thing to make fun of on the
Internet every one of their mother
online is laughing at DJ Khaled's
snapchat being completely just enamored
with just
the guy as a person and I want to
quickly interject as you guys you og
podcast family knows and I'm talking
about like when we podcasted at our old
place two computers shitty mics shitty
camera that that old podcast Jenna even
before that but on one of those really
podcast she was talking about DJ
Khaled's Instagram because that was long
before we got on snapchat she was
talking about his little videos about
him signing [ __ ] being his hot tub
talking about we the best and another
one on Instagram way before anyone
discovered dj khaled on snapchat now
it's like everyone's hilarious because
they're like oh look at DG gotcha I just
want to give credit where it's due
because Jenna discovered this way
[ __ ] before anyone else and no one
seems to remember that that that existed
I just remember the saddest part of that
podcast now in hindsight is that I had
already been completely enamored with
him for like months
even longer than that because I loved I
genuinely loved hip-hop and rap music so
much to the point where dj khaled was a
necessary person for me to follow
because I was genuinely interested in
his life until I realized it was [ __ ]
hysterical then it took me quite a while
to build up the balls to be like is it
is it like okay of me to criticize a big
giant strong wealthy rapper man without
getting in trouble can I even say this
without someone being like [ __ ] you
Jenna I hope that you die yeah you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah no for sure I
remember you showed me all the time you
were talking about it it's just it's a
crazy myth then yeah look a year later
we did that podcast and now a while
later it's like everyone thinks he's so
funny and like guys even had laughing
emoji and had laughing a teacher a
college man anyway the most hipster dj
khaled joke anyone has ever said but
it's true it's like it's just such a
funny situation because you did discover
a way before it's yea popular because
you ever single your I think your
favorite quote is when he signs the is
that is have a favorite DJ guy thought
well I know but it's a quote that's not
a quote and I don't even know if it
still exists but he's in a hot tub
talking about how we the best and I
changed a lot and blah blah blah then he
leans over the side of the hot tub and
signs his name in like a spiral circle
like over
/ / / / / / / / yeah like you know he's
just dripping wet over this contract and
that's not a signature you just colored
it in like you had a crayon in their
hand and you were 5
yeah while he's saying we the best way
the best that's probably my favorite so
funny like there's so many funny things
but yeah I do that anyway sorry for
rambling ah
Sydney Roy says were you content with
the winner of Survivor this season mmm
cuz I know Jenna has the soft spot for
Spencer yeah I'm happy I'm fine with it
okay I'm sorry by the way spoiler or
[ __ ] honor he's boiled everything
forever involving all I said was you
have a soft spot for Spencer
that gave away nothing no yet no Spencer
is weather alert spoiler alert he did
not want to do Domon um Spencer is one
of my favorite all-time survivor players
yeah you loved him from the beginning he
was on his first season yeah yeah well
cuz he reminds me so much of my brother
like you know he's exactly like my
brother so Stephen Fischbach and him are
both like your brother I know I like
anybody that's like sort of a little bit
nerdy and smart plays like that is just
my favorite it's I'm sorry it is what it
is yeah I mean I I like Jeremy the first
season he was on I wasn't huge on him
but I really grew to like him the second
season because I keep [ __ ] Hughes RV
got two eyes it's like you know but yeah
and like eight that's the thing like he
played the game really well he was smart
and he didn't do any dumb [ __ ] like the
first season I kind of felt like he was
flip-flopping socially and it bothered
me but the second season I really could
relate to him because I feel like that's
kind of how I would play and he did a
good job so he deserved it thank you
happy with it if we could get like a
Cochrane Fischbach [ __ ] Spencer
Cochrane I missing Lions yeah that'd be
fantastic from yeah for sure if you guys
could all go on again for my viewing
pleasures so that I could just have an
entire season of my favorite people
would be greatly yeah Jenny you followed
like a bunch of people in Survivor are
you going on Survivor oh my god I talked
about that in my vlog that up like a
long time ago I started following
everybody that's ever been on Survivor
and I got called out basically because
there was a little
underground thread that I've read like
super hardcore survivor fans and they're
like pretty sure jennamarbles is going
on Survivor because she just followed
everybody who's ever been a survivor and
start good indicator because usually
people do that and no dude I just got
[ __ ] called out for being a stalker
that's called the [ __ ] out called the
[ __ ] out of how Stephanie wants to know
Stephanie Clausing says how to get in
the Christmas spirit when you have
finals the day before Christmas Eve my
advice is Kermit Kermit come you naughty
boy you stay though hey here you're
stuck just remember that after your
finals you get to have all the eggnog in
the world I can tell you something that
I've done when I was in school to get in
the Christmas spirit
um if you're done with a lot of your
papers and stuff or any sort of things
that you're not going to keep going into
your next semester what I did was I took
all of them and some blank ones too and
I made paper snowflakes because we
couldn't really afford like ornaments
and stuff or like decorations for our
apartment in college but I like forever
I'm just trying to make people laugh
which is like I had my roommate actually
and I loved making her [ __ ] laugh she
had a really good laugh and we have the
same sense of humor she we would sit in
my [ __ ] room and watch Andy Milonakis
videos for hours because we would just
sit there and cry laughing and I I
decided one day that I really wanted to
make her laugh and we're you know right
around finals before we went home for
Christmas and I taken all of those old
like papers that you would usually throw
out or like worksheets whatever-the-fuck
handouts syllabus whatever and I made
Sandra's of paper snowflakes yeah and
taped them all over the apartment and it
looked like a [ __ ] Christmas
wonderland in there you don't need a lot
of money to see that taken paper like
it's like cleansing it's like yeah rid
of all this old stuff and you turn it
into something really exactly instead of
just turning them out so make them into
paper snowflakes and tape them together
like I made like Garland's and then a
hung individual ones up from the ceiling
so when he walked you're funny
beautiful it was really pretty yeah but
Ashley came home and she started [ __ ]
peeing your pants laugh
like naked can't imagine like a
discovering that let's see we have a lot
of questions we're not going to get
through them all so sorry if we don't
answer yours um do you've any weird
traditions between the two of you not
just holiday traditions we're I think we
uh every time we were getting into a
show we have like a dance for the intro
of the show what show any like TV show
we know yeah like we have a dance for
American Horror Story like SVU oh yeah
began from theme songs we danced to the
intro music we also have the otter dance
yeah we're dancing our hands what else
to make that into something you've gotta
make another something any other
traditions we have not that I can think
of we don't really have any traditions
yeah cuz [ __ ] it all [ __ ] it off we have
a tradition of doing nothing on holidays
you know mom comes for thanks kid yeah
we're gonna do enough we do nothing
yeah it's time to lay down and just have
family time ah Katie wants to know Jenna
get new glasses for Christmas
hell no they're not broken they're
[ __ ] so broke they're not broke I
won't fix them they're broken and you
need to get new ones
here's why they're not broken I can
still see out of them there's my problem
with this because my mom okay aside from
the fact that the lens will fall out on
things and I'll have to find it in the
morning when she sleeps in her glass
[ __ ] like that
I honestly think Jenna would look mad
cute with some new glasses I think you
could pull off some like a really cute
look with some new glasses that aren't
broken ass old ones you have I forget
that those are the only pair of glasses
that you've ever really seen me in which
is a poor showing
because I won't can I disagree I'll
never ever buy like just the cheap
whatever we get she better look
LensCrafters well because first of all
let me explain like my router I only
really wear them like when I don't have
my contacts in so early in the morning
at night or if I'm using my eyes or rest
for the day like I don't need to go out
into the world I think where my glasses
in the world's just doesn't this feels
wrong unless I'm going to run this okay
yeah I like those ones because
I've had like really cute frames with
like thick [ __ ] plastic whatever
colorful I've had purple ones about
every spread like they're really cute
but I found that it was so distracting
to me as like a part time glasses where
to have like a dark distracting ass
funny shaped frame understood that's a
good point
because if I'm not doing it for fashion
I'm literally only doing it so that I
can see but it bothers you because it's
got the ones that have no frame but
there still are like light frames or
thin frames that wouldn't be as much of
a shot of course but I mean that's why I
chose those ones and that's why they're
in such sad shape now but they're old
well I hope that answers your question
she has no plans to buy new glasses
maybe I'll just like Louise I'm on
accident one day no man will be able to
see anything there's a lot of like great
things now where you you send in
prescription they'll give you they'll
send you a bunch of options well you saw
the ones before that that only had one
yes yes yes it had one thing that wasn't
it was no better than the ones you had
and I was wearing them just with the one
thing behind the ear and then it was
like a masquerade mask like sorry just
get some [ __ ] guards my dogs
destroyed both of those keep them in
their glasses case I try
there's no trying there's only do or do
not oh my god just kidding just kidding
is last night and at once you have no so
y'all get you I know what maybe that'll
be your Christmas present no can I find
can I have your prescription please no I
don't even know where it is so that's
half the problem what do people think of
Julian's haircut or um yeah hey people
really like your haircut yeah it was
funny I post on Instagram the day I was
getting it cut saying like goodbye to
the bun and literally thousands of
comments no no no no no no how dare you
how dare ya and then I got a cut and I
was a picture that I caught my god so
it's funny but yeah people have been
really receptive to it
kermin on the other hand isn't like i'm
just uh let's see number one thing on
east of each of our bucket lists shannon
asks that then skylar asked the last
question well i mean i have to figure
out a new one because mine was going to
japan
yeah honestly that was really high up
online - that might have been number one
at least in terms of travel or like
things you want to see yeah ah it was it
was just Tokyo I just wanted to see
Tokyo hmm
so I'm I can't believe that that
happened well not gonna figure it out
what's yours no idea no idea maybe eat
at Gerald's restaurant oh yeah you
really go to that I'd say like shake
hands with Joe Rogan maybe is up there
for me yeah cuz I have admired him for
so many years
yeah driver guns regret he's just such a
[ __ ] cool guy I've no I stuffed I
never thought I would do so I guess I
need to start working on a real bucket
list maybe I'll get back to you on that
sorry oh I know I would like to breathe
the same air that Seth MacFarlane
one-time breathes - Prost Prost Russ I
think the correct is breath method I
don't think I could meet him though
because I'm pretty sure I pass out so
probably not that but just breathe the
same air mmm that'd be cool
um I've breath the same air ISM it's not
golf out of here so Jones Papa let's
pick one last question
yeah all right let's find a good one
let's find a really good one okay here's
a good one Rihanna
Mefford asks which people are things do
you look for or look to for inspiration
hmm well you got to go first
um well there's a couple different like
sources or you know arenas in my life
that I'm in spot that I need inspiration
for yeah so there's say there's making
vlogs need inspiration for that there's
being a good human race without there's
fitness stuff like that I would
definitely say you know to an extent my
parents they're they're inspiring to me
a lot of the vloggers i watch on the
internet have greatly inspired me
you inspire me that's for sure there's a
couple um no it's kind of hard
sorry one to her question I feel like I
all but really we're on the last
question I look - like I come from a
very strong family of women so all of
them like for example my [ __ ] Aunt
Mary who I've talked about where she was
amazing she's been to like over a
hundred countries and I know they had
their special club for that like if you
had know over a hundred countries and I
get a bad one it is like that um she's
just so she's inspiring to be around
because she's you know in her 70s and
just a [ __ ] G like she is kind to
everyone she loves everyone she works
her [ __ ] ass off yeah and she's so
cultured so wonderful and she worked in
the Library of Congress like she's just
such a [ __ ] G yeah you know like [ __ ]
everybody that is an actor or whatever
the [ __ ] like that's my inspiration like
somebody that just has a wonderful
disposition in life and just achieves
things without anybody else's approval
like you just go for what you want
I like that and my I had an advisor in
graduate school that I looked up to and
will always look up to [ __ ] like I when
I met her I was like if I could grow up
in half the person told me about her
really [ __ ] unbelievable I believe
you yeah but in terms of I don't know
silly happy fun that sort of thing I
Seth MacFarland is like mom kids that
this and I love like Joel [ __ ] Rogen
to me honestly because I love the way
that he has built his career he started
as a comedian host encouraged to stand
up all of that and like your life takes
you in a different path he gave no [ __ ]
he does what he wants and now I think he
seems or at least appears to be doing
what he wants
day in and day out cares about and if
ever it was becoming the point where he
didn't want to do anymore he wouldn't do
it him
and I've been asked the question before
like if you had to emulate someone
else's career whose would it be and I
was like [ __ ] Joe Rogan's because he
I don't care about you know getting to a
certain level of success or whatever
it's all about to me like what makes you
happy and what do you want to do what do
you want to spend your time in your life
doing and to me he sort of embodies that
so yeah absolutely not that I would ever
have a parallel sort of path because
it's just like like no it's probably not
gonna go there well not literally right
exactly but I just admire someone who
has taken their strengths and passions
in life and made something that they can
wake up every day and be like this is
what I want to [ __ ] absolutely it's all
about everybody plus he's a bad
[ __ ] yes he is well there you go
you're not inspired by anybody else we
go I don't know I can't I think of
certain specifics right right at this
moment I know it's gonna cone any later
like certain people that I think of I
get inspired by hmm um you're inspired
by a lot of weight lifters and yeah
jiu-jitsu I know you are
you see fighters yeah you like a lot of
people yeah but like on the level of
like really relating to how they do
things I know there's a couple people I
just cannot you love you friends yeah
good friends good friends inspire me for
sure yeah I don't know the people that I
look up to is never for like doing
something really [ __ ] groundbreaking
it's just for being like really decent
human beings yeah for sure you know yeah
huh well maybe when I do think of it I
will tell you guys another time but I'm
definitely inspired by a lot of people
and I think you answer that question
pretty well mm-hmm right thank you guys
for sending us your questions and
hopefully we answered your sir if we did
not there would be more of these
hopefully in the future at some point ah
we will be back next week with another
podcast um good dog family guys more
mostly good guys were okay it was yes I
gave you guys a beef
is every month Paige get to see my
Picchu dicey but everyone passed so
that's all that matters
we love you guys we hope you have a
wonderful holiday with your loved ones
and whatever you're doing if you're
happy thank you guys for spending yet
another holiday with us on the podcast
we really appreciate it
see you guys later